Transcription: Juliet Vdt
Relecteur: Morgane Quilfen
Bonjour, ça va bien ?
Il me faut une zapette,
parce que j'ai un support vidéo
et je n'ai pas la télécommande,
comme quoi, on a tous des ratés.
On va commencer comme ça,
je vais faire des signes.
Je vais vous raconter une histoire
qui commence pendant
la Seconde Guerre mondiale.
A l'époque, les Britanniques bombardent
les lignes allemandes avec leurs avions
et les Allemands prennent ça plutôt mal,
ce qui fait qu'ils vont répondre
en canardant les avions
et comme la guerre, c'est pas très rigolo,
à peu près 50% des avions sont abattus,
sont perdus, disparaissent.
Ceux qui restent arrivent à bon port,
plus ou moins endommagés.
Les Anglais, qui aimeraient bien garder
un peu d'avions en vie
et des pilotes avec,
engagent des scientifiques
en leur disant :
« Trouvez-nous une solution,
on aimerait que ça se passe mieux. »
Il faudrait blinder les avions
pour qu'ils soient plus solides.
Mais un avion entièrement blindé -
merci infiniment -
un avion entièrement blindé, ça s'appelle
un char d'assaut, ça vole très mal.
Y en a qui ont essayé.
Donc il faut trouver
les bons endroits à blinder.
On fait des études, les chercheurs
regardent les avions rescapés
Donc on a des zones
qui sont très touchées,
d'autres qui le sont moins.
L'État-Major, sur la base de ces données,
décide de blinder les zones rouges.
C'est une décision parfaitement logique,
on est d'accord avec ça.
Abraham Wald n'était pas d'accord avec ça.
Il leur a dit : « Si vous voulez
blinder ces zones-là,
vous oubliez de prendre en compte 50%
des avions, ceux qui ne sont pas revenus.
Parce que, ce que nous donnent
comme information ces zones rouges,
ce sont les zones où l'avion
peut être touché, endommagé gravement,
et rentrer quand même.
Donc il faut blinder ailleurs. »
C'est contre-intuitif
mais c'est hyper important.
Ça, c'est le biais du survivant.
Quand on oublie de prendre en compte
ceux qui sont morts...
Par exemple,
(Rires)
un motard ou un soldat
qui rentre sans sa tête, c'est rare.
Donc l'équipement le plus important,
en sécurité, c'est le casque.
Ça, ce sont les morts
qui n'ont plus de tête qui nous disent :
« Là, il faut peut-être
qu'on blinde la tête. »
Le biais du survivant -
c'est de ça dont je vais vous parler -
c'est le biais qui consiste à oublier
les données invisibles :
les morts,
et à ne considérer que ce qu'on voit.
Le problème des conférences TED,
c'est peut-être ça.
Je viens plomber l'ambiance ce soir.
Parce qu'on a tous
des informations sur le monde,
mais ce concept du monde est assez limité.
On a accès à une petite fraction,
ce sont les informations disponibles,
et on pourrait savoir beaucoup de choses,
on pourrait savoir tout ça,
mais on ne sait que
la petite portion qui est blanche.
On sait bien que ce n'est pas suffisant.
On sait que c'est limité.
Mais on veut quand même avoir une opinion,
on veut pouvoir prendre des décisions,
faire des choix.
Donc on le fait.
Des fois, on devrait se retenir,
mais on n'y arrive pas.
Pire parfois, on est obligé
de prendre des décisions, de voter, etc.
Et on le fait sur la base d'informations
qui sont incomplètes
et on oublie qu'elles sont incomplètes,
ce qui fait qu'on ne retient pas
ce qu'il y a autour.
Donc on va combler les trous
avec des inférences personnelles :
quels sont mes intérêts,
mes choix personnels,
mes goûts, mes habitudes.
Et on va remplir nos décisions
avec une explication
parfaitement rationnelle,
mais fausse, fictive,
parce qu'on remplit les trous.
Donc, le biais du survivant,
c'est de se baser sur ce qu'on voit
et d'oublier qu'on n'a pas accès au reste.
Mais le problème, peut-être
que vous êtes déjà au courant, c'est :
les fake news, ça existe.
Tout ce qu'on -
alors, je vais vous choquer :
tout ce qu'on entend n'est pas vrai.
Parfois, il y a de la publicité,
il y a des propagandes dans tous les pays,
il y a des pseudosciences
sur toutes les chaînes,
il y a du bullshit - ça veut dire
conneries ou balivernes -
il y a des purs mensonges,
et il ne faut pas les croire, OK ?
Malheureusement, on est au courant
que votre voisine, votre tante Simone
ou votre petit cousin, ils y croient.
Donc comment on fait
quand on est abreuvé tous les jours
de produits cognitifs avariés ?
On va avoir tendance
à en croire une fraction.
Plus on en entend, plus on va en croire,
parce que c'est mathématique.
Le problème c'est que,
jusque dans cette salle,
je vous regarde, je vous vois très bien,
jusque chez les gens qui regardent
via internet ou sur leur écran,
il y a des croyances fausses.
On a tous ici, des croyances fausses.
Même ici !
Avant moi ou même pendant
que je vous parle,
il y a des gens qui disent des choses,
avec des croyances fausses.
Et comment est-ce qu'on sait
que c'est faux ou que c'est pas faux ?
Je vous renvoie vers qui a été dit avant,
parce que c'était très bien
et vous êtes armé pour être critique,
mais il est possible qu'on croie
des choses fausses
et c'est quand même bien dommage.
Alors c'est déjà une information
relativement délicate,
mais j'ai même pire à vous dire :
à côté des fake news, il y a
un truc que vous ne connaissez pas,
ce sont les mute news -
« mute », ça veut dire
« silencieux », « muet » -
ce sont les choses vraies
que vous ne savez pas,
que vous n'entendez pas
et que vous ne cherchez pas.
Vous les entendrez jamais.
(Rires)
Il y a plein de trucs vrais
que vous n'avez aucune chance de croire,
parce que vous n'êtes pas exposé
à ces choses-là.
D'un côté, on a les choses fausses
qui prennent beaucoup de place,
en face, on a les choses vraies
qu'on ne cherche pas
car on n'est pas motivé
à chercher les choses vraies
parce que c'est coûteux.
Donc vous venez ici -
regardez, c'est là, on reconnaît ?
Vous venez ici, vous payez votre place
pour écouter des gens,
vous avez un panel de conférenciers
et vous vous dites :
« Qui est-ce qu'on vient écouter ? »
C'est pas n'importe qui
qui vient parler, à part moi.
Ce sont des gens qui sont là,
à qui on donne la parole,
parce qu'on estime qu'ils ont
un truc intéressant à dire.
Donc on ne va pas aller interroger
le clodo du coin,
la personne qui a raté sa vie,
on ne le fait pas.
On va s'intéresser
à des gens intéressants.
Qui fait ça ?
Les organisateurs, qui sont adorables.
Ils sont là-bas, coucou.
Mais ils ont leurs biais personnels,
leurs opinions, leurs croyances.
Peut-être qu'ils ont leurs défauts à eux ?
Je suppose que ça doit arriver.
Comment est-ce qu'ils font un choix ?
Ils font un choix qui va être -
ils vont prendre des gens qui sont -
ce ne sont pas les avions crashés,
ce sont les survivants,
les gens qui ont la parole
sur cette scène,
c'est une fraction,
on n'a pas accès à ce que disent
les gens hors de la scène.
Vous avez peut-être des trucs à dire
mais le micro, c'est moi qui l'ai
donc c'est moi qui parle.
(Rires)
A partir de là, qu'est-ce que
je peux vous raconter ?
La devise des conférences TED, c'est :
« Des idées qui valent
la peine d'être diffusées ».
C'est ce qui est intéressant.
Qui décide de ça ?
C'est les gens qui invitent les gens.
Une idée intéressante,
elle n'est pas forcément vraie.
Ce qui est intéressant n'est pas toujours
utile pour comprendre le monde.
Ce qui est intéressant,
c'est ce qui est intéressant,
on est bien avancé.
Donc on entend régulièrement
dans le format « conférence TED »,
un peu moins ce soir,
mais ça arrive souvent,
des gens qui vont vous parler de trucs
qui sont à la mode, subversifs,
choquants, amusants.
Il y a plein de moyens de trouver
un truc intéressant.
Quels sont les filtres qu'on utilise
pour choisir les sujets ?
Certes, c'est intéressant,
mais est-ce que ça vaut le coup
d'être diffusé ?
Ça se discute et je n'ai pas la réponse.
(Rires)
Désolé, on fait ce qu'on peut.
Le problème, c'est la persistance
des croyances réfutées.
On vous en a parlé tout à l'heure,
on a tous des croyances fausses
et on les garde pour plein de raisons
et surtout, parce que on ne veut pas
savoir à quel point on est ignorant,
que l'on ne sait que ça.
On veut croire qu'on sait des choses.
On ne veut pas être incertain :
c'est inconfortable.
Du coup, on va se flatter
de croire des choses,
on va écouter des gens
qui nous racontent des histoires
et on adore les histoires de réussite.
On va venir nous raconter que :
Bill Gates, il est super
parce qu'il a fait ça,
ou Elon Musk ou Steve Jobs,
cherchez bien, Il y a plein
de conférences TED
où on vous raconte la vie de ces gens-là
ou d'autres qui ont réussi,
ou eux viennent vous parler de leur vie,
mais les gens qui réussissent sont-ils
experts de leur réussite personnelle ?
Est-ce qu'ils savent
pourquoi ils ont réussi ?
Je ne sais pas non plus,
parce que je n'ai pas la réponse à tout.
En tout cas, eux et ceux qui viennent
vous parler de la réussite des autres,
ils vous livrent des récits motivants,
stimulants, édifiants, inspirants,
il manque un mot qui est
moins à la mode, c'est pertinent.
Ce n'est pas toujours pertinent,
ce qu'on entend.
Parce qu'au final, ce sont des gens
qui viennent vous parler de réussite,
d'obstacles qu'on a surmontés.
On se réalise soi-même, vous voyez ?
Donc en gros, on vous parle
de réussite et de motivation
mais c'est important : 100% des cadavres
qui jalonnent le mont Everest
ont autrefois été des gens
extrêmement motivés.
(Rires)
Celui qui meurt comparé
à celui qui rentre,
ce n'est pas qu'il était moins motivé.
Il y a autre chose qui a joué :
la chance, le hasard, l'organisation,
mais être motivé,
ce n'est jamais suffisant.
Oui, Bill Gates, il était très motivé.
Ce n'est pas pour ça qu'il a réussi.
Donc on a des récits intéressants
et c'est super intéressant.
Mais est-ce qu'on apprend
quelque chose de ça ?
Donc je vous parle de réussites -
et on sait tous en vrai,
cherchez bien au fond de vous,
on sait bien qu'on apprend
beaucoup plus de nos échecs.
La preuve en images :
c'est écrit plus gros.
(Rires)
On apprend beaucoup plus,
parce que quand on réussit tout le temps,
peut-être qu'on n'a pas trouvé
l'élément important pour réussir.
Mais quand on échoue,
on cherche ce qui a raté
et on trouve ce qu'on a raté
et là, on a appris un truc.
A force d'écouter ceux qui réussissent,
qui vous disent :
« C'est facile, il suffit de le vouloir.
Tu vois, c'est pas compliqué. »
Et quand on n'écoute pas
le mec à côté, qui a raté, qui dit :
« Moi j'en ai bavé
et j'étais aussi motivé que les autres »,
on croit que motivé, c'est suffisant.
Grosse erreur.
Mais on aime bien ces récits-là
pour diverses raisons :
à cause du biais du survivant
mais à cause aussi du biais
qu'on appelle l'internalité :
l'erreur fondamentale d'attribution.
Épisode 9 de « La Tronche en Biais »,
allez voir, abonnez-vous.
C'est le fait qu'on veuille
que nos succès soient explicables
par nos qualités personnelles :
« C'est parce que je suis moi,
talentueux, que je réussis. »
Et du coup en face, les échecs,
c'est à cause des autres.
Si je veux croire cela,
j'ai besoin d'écouter
ceux qui réussissent pour faire comme eux,
Parce qu'eux, grâce à leurs qualités
et à leur démarche, ils ont réussi.
Ce biais-là, il est extrêmement pervers,
parce que d'une part,
je néglige de m'intéresser aux échecs,
je crois que mes qualités personnelles
vont me permettre de réussir,
et je vais blâmer ceux
qui ne réussissent pas
parce que c'est leur faute.
Mais si on regarde les vrais critères
qui déterminent si on va réussir sa vie.
Riche ou pauvre, en fait.
Je vais vous dire un truc qu'on ne
vous dit jamais en conférence TED :
le travail, la motivation,
certes, c'est vachement bien -
soyez motivé, travaillez bien -
mais en réalité, c'est :
qui sont vos parents,
quelle langue vous parlez,
quelle école vous fréquentez,
vos amis, les réseaux autour de vous,
les opportunités
que vous avez la chance d'avoir.
Le hasard :
c'est ça qui détermine, en gros,
vos réussites ou vos échecs.
Et ça, vous n'y pouvez rien.
Quand je vous dis ça,
je vous dépossède de votre pouvoir
à décider de votre vie.
Je suis le méchant de l'histoire,
je suis désolé, c'est comme ça.
Donc on est très motivé à ne pas le croire
et très motivé à écouter
ce que disent les autres.
Moi, on m'ignore
mais si on m'invite, je parle.
Merci beaucoup pour l'invitation.
Conclusion : méfiez-vous de vous-même.
Méfions-nous de nous-mêmes.
Méfiez-vous du format TED Talk,
des conférences,
qui va vous brosser dans le sens du poil.
Méfiez-vous de moi, évidemment,
parce que je ne suis personne
et je n'ai pas d'autorité
pour vous dire de qui vous méfier.
Et faites attention au fait
qu'il suffirait de vous poser la question
et de ralentir vos inférences
pour vous demander : mais est-ce que
ce que je crois est vrai ou faux ?
Parce qu'être intelligent, c'est avoir
un gros moteur dans le bolide,
et être rationnel,
c'est avoir un bon frein.
Si vous ne freinez jamais,
vous irez dans le mur.
Et si vous êtes un gros bolide,
vous allez taper fort dans le mur.
Donc on peut être
hyper intelligent et hyper biaisé,
donc méfiez-vous des gens intelligents
plus que des autres
parce que quand ils se plantent,
ils se plantent plus fort.
Et comme on est ici
entre gens de bonne compagnie,
intelligents, éduqués, etc.
méfiez-vous de vous,
vous êtes les personnes
les plus dangereuses dans cette pièce
parce que vous êtes les seuls.
Merci beaucoup.
(Applaudissements)